lost in the conversation shireen
regarding social justice an important
conversation that had to happen
what's happening with the washington
football team the number after the
washington post article from wednesday
of former female employees who claim
sexual harassment endured while working
for the organization is now at 42
and counting and the big story yesterday
and i think the the biggest issue as it
relates to that that claim of sexual
harassment the decision of the nfl to
defer
to
washington owner daniel snyder's hire of
his own investigator to come in and try
to get to the bottom of all of this in
the nfl's refusal to have an independent
investigation that is astounding to me
an independent investigation needs to
happen and until an independent
investigation occurs it's going to be
impossible for anyone to know exactly
what went on in that organization over
the last 21 years
this is at least as bad as what happened
in carolina with jerry richardson if not
worse and they did do an independent
investigation and jerry richardson ended
up making it easy on him because he
walked away before that
investigation was complete but if you
did that at carolina why aren't you
doing this at washington
i i'm flabbergasted that the league is
not doing its own investigation that
they don't
probably suspend dan snyder at this
point until there is some conclusion to
the investigation i you know they they
repeatedly say including roger goodell
they repeatedly say that we hold those
that are coach
gm's owners to a higher standard than
the players if there's a higher standard
then put him on the commissioner exempt
list and and do an investigation because
that's what they would do with the
player if he was involved in some of
this
there was a letter sent yesterday by the
firm of cats marshall and banks to the
commissioner that firm represents more
than 12 former washington employees who
claim sexual harassment the lawsuits are
coming and frankly civil litigation may
be the only way to get to the truth here
if there won't be a truly independent
investigation but they make it clear on
page two of this letter and here's the
quote our clients would gladly
participate in an nfl investigation they
do not feel safe
speaking to investigators hired by mr
snyder and do not trust the
investigation that is currently underway
that's what we said yesterday
right if beth wilkinson who was hired by
daniel schneider to investigate daniel
snyder
is going to call these former employees
she has no subpoena power she has no
authority whatsoever to get them to talk
they're going to hang up the phone
we're not going to talk to the
investigator who's been hired by daniel
schneider and who may have
the agenda of twisting our words in a
way that minimizes the impact
potentially a lot on a liability
perspective of of what may happen or
what the consequence may be to daniel
schneider no they're not going to
cooperate with her they are far more
likely to cooperate with the nfl and
that's what this letter makes clear and
you know again i i don't know what the
nfl is going to do about it i know the
nfl's got its hands full but shereen
this seems like the easiest problem for
the nfl to fix right now hire an
independent investigator
yeah it's it's simple hire the
investigator suspend insider until you
come up with results it's not that hard
but they're they're making it harder
than what it is
and he claims he's been hands off that's
one of his defenses don't blame me if
you're hands off
suspending him during the investigation
means nothing to the team if you're
hands off so uh we'll see how that plays
out it's an important topic that can't
get lost and everything else we're
discussing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports